Now we want to see how to insert an element, here is my partially filled array.
And I want to insert an element before this position. So I need to move all of
these elements out of the way, so that the green element can go into the slot.
Now, you have to be a bit careful with the move out of the way part. If I were
to move this element over here, and then this element over here and so on. That
will be bad because then this element would override the next one before I had
a chance to move that one out of the way. So, in other words, this element
would flood the entire tail of the array. The remedy is to do the movement
starting at the end of the array. So, I first move this one, then it's
predecessor, then it's predecessor. And I keep going until I've moved the one
into who's slot that I want to put the new one. The other thing to remember is
that insertion increases the size, so I have to make sure to add one to size of
my partially filled array. Le'ts look at this in Java code. I increase the
size. Here is the loop to make room for the new element. So when I increase my
size then I am starting at size minus 1, which is same as the old size. I now
go backwards. And each of the moves goes the other direction than the one that
you've seen with removal. It goes from a lower index to a higher index. And the
last movement is the one that moves pos to pos plus 1, so we want this one to
be pos, which means we want I to be plus, plus one and that's where we stop.
Finally, when we're all done, we can insert the new value after position pos.
As you have seen inserting and removing array elements requires quite a bit of
movement. You need to move elements out of the way, in the case of insertion,
or move them to close up the gap in the situation of removal. It was also easy
with the array list, where you just called add and removed. But the reason
that, as explained to you, what actually goes on with arrays, is an array list
has a partially filled array inside it, and it's sometimes important to know
which operations are cheap, and which ones are expensive. And sorting and
removing can be expensive for a long array.